This is a data story.
[Music]
79% of executives scaling intelligentautomation expect to outperform their competition
in revenue growth over the next three years.
Tomanage global disruptions, leaders are innovating and investing in automated intelligentworkflows.
They're embedding predictive insights and increasing automation with AI-poweredworkflows and data mining.
They're applying open innovation and collaboration as they optimizethese workflows with their ecosystem partners
and they are fast-tracking risk management,
increasing modeling and with a deeper focus on predictability, simulation and visualization.
Rightnow, innovator CSCOs report developing digitized workflows and leveraging AI automation
a full95% more than their peers.
Priorities are shifting and these new transformational approachesare helping them prepare for whatever comes next.